[Music]
hundreds of clark county homeowners
rushed out to the assessor's office
today hoping to meet a major deadline
several of them fearful their property
tax will soar to 8 percent
that's a huge hike with everything going
on right now that's a very huge hike i
mean who can afford it i mean it's just
ridiculous don't panic they're going to
have you fill out a form
hundreds of homeowners rushed to the
assessor's office on wednesday fearful
of a deadline they believed would push
property taxes through the roof my
co-worker sent me a link and said my
home was at eight percent go check i
checked online and it said eight for
mine many like the williams claiming the
county's website and phone lines were
not working we tried to do that this
morning it didn't work so we just came
up here and then we see all the other
people that it must have didn't work for
them either clark county assessor
brianna johnson apologizing to all
residents over this video call and
claims the rush was not necessary she
says only homeowners who recently
purchased a home or had a change in
their title need to come forward check
which box signing dated
johnson stated it's the homeowner's
responsibility to inform her office if
their home is their primary residence
which would cap their taxes at three
percent otherwise eight percent would be
the default for properties like
commercial or open land regardless
adjustments throughout the fiscal year
can be made she says until june of 2023
for this couple they blame the lack of
organization from the county for the
mess we were blessed we took care of it
and we're good
thank you so much
well the clark county assessor brianna
johnson stressed that adjustments on
property taxes can always be made
throughout the fiscal year so there
really is no need to worry now head over
to 8newsnow.com right now there you can
find a link to take necessary action if
needed